mein thema ist heute abend eher eine
frage ich frage mich dass ja schon
länger aber heute auch mal wieder wollen
die grünen eigentlich die lebensfreude
verbieten nicht darauf komme der
gesundheitspolitiker janosch dahmen hält
die ausrichtung des oktoberfestes in
münchen für unvernünftig es bestehe die
gefahr dass kronor mit neuer härte
zurück kommen zudem warnt er vor harten
neuen virusvariante geht's noch warum
vermisst uns janosch dahmen die
sommerlaune und prophezeit dinge die ihr
gar nicht hervor sehen kann von den
wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen die eine
dritte absage des oktoberfests zur folge
hätte ganz zu schweigen kommen wir
lieber zu der wichtigsten frage wann
sind wir bloß in die endlosschleife
panik getrieben ja politiker geraten und
diese frage möchte ich gerne direkt an
frau zypries geben vielleicht sieht sie
auch anders ich sehe es definitiv anders
erstens mal kenne ich diesen
gesundheitspolitiker überhaupt nicht
scheint mir jetzt nicht so die erste
reihe zu sein und ich finde jährige
heinz büse sprecher schlechthin oder wie
als bundestag
sprecher der grünen ja ok aber
ich meine man kann jetzt irgendwie nicht
auf jede meinung eingehen und man kann
nicht jedes problem irgendwie dann auch
gleich kontrovers oder oder sich
anziehen sag ich mal ich glaube man muss
auch irgendwann mal sagen okay kann der
ja so sehen warten wir erstmal business
variante kommt mag die regierung das
vorbereiten das halte ich für richtig
dass es wenn es so sein kann dann ist es
richtig man bereitet sich darauf vor
aber das war es dann auch finden sie
diese panikmache richtig allein die
finde ich nicht richtig hin also jetzt
mal nicht über den politiker speziell
aber es ist ja schon synonym dafür das
machen ja auch andere politiker leider
jetzt schon wieder von neuen virus
varianten gewarnt für die jetzt schon
wieder aufs oktoberfest geblickt wird
muss man den menschen nicht mal eine
krone atempause geben naja die krone
atempause kann man nur geben wenn man
kein krone hat deswegen ist es sinnvoll
man beobachtet die fallzahlen und man
reagiert dann aber es macht keinen sinn
zu sagen wer weiß was wir in drei
monaten für fallzahlen haben und
deswegen machen wir jetzt schon mal
dieses oder jenes man hat fast ein
bisschen so das gefühl finde ich
irgendwie als wollen manche gar keine
corona pause haben sondern irgendwie
diese durchgehendes panik level bis zum
herbst durchmarschieren lassen weil
genau genommen weiß keiner von uns was
im herbst kommen wird und
ich warte ehrlich gesagt eher gespannt
endlich auf die evaluierung der korona
maßnahmen und auf ihre wirksamkeit ich
glaube dass unsere regierung mehr damit
zu tun haben müsste eigentlich uns
endlich zu erklären welche maßnahmen
eigentlich sinnvoll waren und welche
nicht vor allen dingen im hinblick auf
den herbst weil dort drohen ja wieder
neue maßnahmen oder das maßnahmen
zurückkehren und bevor die wieder neu
erlassen werden also angefangen
irgendwie von kontakt beschränkungen
schulschließung und so weiter hätte ich
gerne jetzt eigentlich mal eine
evaluierung welche dieser maßnahmen
überhaupt jemals sinnvoll waren denn nur
sinnvolle maßnahmen können wir im herbst
auch wieder wiederholen
januar starben ist ja jemand der nicht
so bekannt ist das stimmt leider relativ
neu ist im bundestag es aber so ein hat
sich ein mann vom fach als ausgebildeter
rettungshund glauben also luft
rettungszentrum geleitet also weiß aus
der praxis zumindest als arzt bevor er
als gesundheitspolitischer sprecher
spricht
auch allerdings bin ich auch da anderer
meinung weil ich meine wir müssen auch
an die wirtschaftlichen folgen denken
was jetzt hier passiert wie ich meine
jetzt wird wieder die die die quasi die
sorge geweckt was ist denn jetzt mit dem
oktoberfest der sind hunderte von leuten
involviert wirtschaftlich involviert die
zwei mal große ausfälle gehabt haben in
münchen die vertrauen jetzt den ansagen
ihre bürgermeisters ihres
ministerpräsidenten
die gesagt haben okay das oktoberfest
findet statt und jetzt kommt wieder die
die die die große angst glocke von der
absage des oktoberfestes da bin ich
dafür dass man ein bisschen pragmatische
gesagt okay wir überlegen wenn die
situation sich zuspitzt dann nur mit
test- oder wie auch immer aber von
vornherein die verbote ried ist jetzt
auszurufen zum dritten mal in folge das
zeug nicht viel von auch
wirtschaftlichem sachverstand in dieser
sache aber ich kann ihnen sagen ich bin
ja selber eventmanager und habe zwei
jahre extrem oder dieser pandemie
gelitten weil ich so viel verloren habe
dass man sich gar nicht vorstellen kann
und als wir letztes jahr wieder mit dem
csd auf die straße gehen wollt nun den
charakteren garantien hygiene konzept
vorgelegt haben nämlich masken zu tragen
was uns dann ja auch
genehmigt wurde und wir das gemacht
haben wir haben fragen offen ausgetragen
dann wurden wir auch hier aus eurem haus
kritisiert dass es einige gibt die keine
getragen haben war gleichzeitig das beim
nena konzert irgendwie und man erinnert
sich noch so leicht daran
irgendwie die leute in einzelne ecken
100 heißt es noch ganz genau und wir
von vielen medien also ich will das
jetzt auch gar nicht nur auf die medien
schieben sondern wir ja eher sagen dass
verlangen das sehe ich jetzt ja aktuell
ich weiß über über den winter viel in
den staaten weil ich einfach die korona
maßnahmen teilweise eben auch ein
bisschen davon entfliehen wollte und
nicht die ganze zeit maske tragen wollte
und dort hat man ja schon sehr in
freiheit dann gelebt aber wenn ich jetzt
hier bin wie viele menschen ist immer
noch freiwillig tragen weil sie immer
noch angst haben da muss man doch sagen
das ist vielleicht nicht unbedingt die
mehrheit die das so toll findet das
alles einfach gelockert wird und
aufgehoben wird also man sollte schon
danach gucken wer wer will dass also
einfach pauschal zu sagen die mehrheit
ist dagegen ist jetzt auch irgendwie
nicht glauben dass ich das thema
ehrlicherweise ich meine jeder sollte
sich so schützen wie er es oder sie es
für richtig halten das aber muss man ein
fest verbieten was überwiegend im freien
stattfindet absolut das haben wir bei
der demo hier erlebt und mussten die
maske tragen natürlich obwohl alle
wissenschaftler ja schon im sommer zwar
nicht aber netten letzten 21 aber man
musste ja schon im nach dem ersten
locker und das draußen der ansteckung
sehr gering ist ja jetzt langsam
wirklich absurd mit allem respekt vor
dem csd gewissen das ist ja nicht nur
eine feier zum die rechte von
homosexuellen transferieren und anderen
minderheiten zu stärken sondern ist
mittlerweile ja auch ein großes
volksfest wo viele menschen kommen und
dann diese politische botschaft aller
nehmen das ist eine demonstration seien
wir ehrlich ist eine demonstration sie
sagen ist eine demonstration gesamte der
demonstration angemeldet das ist
sicherlich auch herr angewiesen mit
sicherheit auch ein volksfest und es ist
aber mit sehr viel spaß und mit sehr
viel freude und diese bilder werden doch
auch vermittelt also zeigen sie mir
einen csd wo nicht getanzt gelacht wird
geschunkelt wird und auf den wagen die
große party abgeht mit politischer
botschaft das bestreitet ja kein mensch
aber mit dem kerner du dich dabei freude
und spaß zu haben ich wollte aber auch
was anderes hinaus aber wahrscheinlich
als keiner am kreuz gehabt zu sagen der
csd findet nicht statt
aber jetzt zu sagen das oktoberfest
sollen die stattfinden das ist
eigentlich völlig ab so ich bin absolut
dagegen sieht das genauso wir nur sagen
dass ich das gefühl wird das immer noch
so viele deutsche also ich weiss nicht
die prozentzahl aber dass ich dass er
selber merke wie ich viele immer noch
das verlangen nach gewissen regeln haben
und das sollte doch im freiwillig es
sollte doch jeder für sich entscheiden
also wenn ich ins team gehe dann gibt es
immer noch ich kann jetzt keine
prozentzahl sagen aber gibt es immer
noch einen gewissen anteil von menschen
und die sind 20 25 70 und 80 also ganz
unterschiedlich die immer noch
freiwillig maske tragen obwohl sie es
nicht müssen aber sollen ja aber die
frage ist müssen wir uns der angst
sozusagen aufgaben beugen und da und ich
wesentlich zeit einen unterschied zu
machen dass man sagt jemand dem ist
jemand dem es angst macht auf einen csd
zu gehen oder ins zum oktoberfest zu
gehen weil er glaubt dass es sich dort
an steckt der soll zu hause bleiben also
ich finde inzwischen ist es einfach so
dass die gesellschaft in die ihre
freiheit wieder zurück haben muss und
diejenigen die angst haben die müssen
selber schauen wie sie die selbst den
abstand halten aber wir können nicht
mehr verlangen dass ein ganzes volk eben
seine freiheit aufgibt nur weil manche
menschen in ihrer angst bleiben möchte
diejenigen schützen mit einer fft zwei
maskierte und es geht natürlich auch um
die frage welche varianten sind es und
da kommen wir wieder auf ihren
gesundheitspolitischen sprecher der
grünen der ja offenbar von einer
variante ausgeht die wir heute noch gar
nicht kennen und das ist ja das problem
also bei dem was wir heute haben können
wir sagen wir können das alles so frei
geben jeder soll selber machen weil wenn
man halbwegs ordentlich geimpft ist dann
passiert einem nicht so sonderlich viel
selbst wenn man sich infiziert
aber wenn es natürlich eine variante
gibt die gegen die dass der imf sehr um
das impfserum nicht wirkt und wir dann
irgendwie diese variante bekommen dann
haben wir wieder eine ganz andere
diskussion aber ja ich meine das ist
irgendwie so wie asterix immer gesagt
hat kann sein dass uns selber laufen
kopf fällt gar
nicht wenn du bist doch ein thema das
die die gedanken über selbstmord bei
kindern den jugendlichen sich
verdreifacht haben werden der kona
pandemie das irgendwie menschen eben
veranstalter kultur alle gelitten und
wenn ich hier durch berlin gehe dann
habe ich das gefühl alle tun wieder so
als wäre nie etwas gewesen
ich finde da sollte man jetzt eher
darüber über die spätfolgen auch von
maßnahmen aber von allen von der
gesamten corona pandemie